how do we
make peace with our memory
see how do you make peace with something
that doesn't exist
but we have it so we're in this
conundrum
see the memory is there there is no such
reality
it you are misunderstanding your
psychological process as a reality that
is the fundamental mistake
your thought and emotion you think it is
real
it is not it's just something that
you're making up
if you know you're making it up
then what is the problem there's nothing
to deal with
because it doesn't exist
the problem is you've been you've been
given a very complex
level of intelligence which includes
memory and imagination
but you don't have a stable enough
platform
this platform is not stable enough you
know
let me put it like this you heard of
that english guy you because you were in
uk for some time you must have met this
guy called charles darwin did you meet
him no no
didn't happen in some way you met him in
the school textbook at least okay yeah
exactly
exactly
so charles darwin went out to say that a
goat could have become a giraffe in some
million years a pig could have become an
elephant in many more million years
something something like this all right
an ant could have become on a dinosaur
right over a billion years whatever
but a monkey became a man rather quickly
i mean a woman also
okay don't take it
you know how many times i've been
generalized as a guy it does not bother
me so
so if a monkey became a human being
rather too quickly
how quickly means
the dna difference between a chimpanzee
and a human being is only 1.23 percent
one point two three percent is not much
of a difference isn't it
so physiologically that is how close you
are to a chimpanzee but in terms of
intelligence and awareness your worlds
apart so essentially human beings do not
know how to handle their own
intelligence because they don't have a
stable enough platform
one important and significant aspect of
the yogic sciences is to create a stable
platform
so that your intelligence works for you
if your intelligence works for you would
you keep yourself blissful or miserable
just bless bliss
if you are in some way miserable for
whatever reason for whatever reason you
just lost a race or you crashed your car
whatever the hell the reason is if you
are miserable it simply means
your intelligence is working against you
it's as simple as that and you're in the
memory
and you're in the memory uh your
intelligence is not working for you that
means it doesn't decipher what is
reality and what is memory what is
reality and what is imagination
how do we get our intelligence to work
for us before the race are you taking
anti-diarrheal pills
no some people are i know
because imagination
is going wild
this is human predicament you do not
know how to handle your own intelligence
that is the thing if you had the brain
of an earthworm you would be peaceful
no nerves
now to intelligence
is is it a solution or is it a problem
question i don't know it sounds like
it's a problem after all this what
should it be
intelligence is a solution
intelligence is a solution for
everything isn't it but human beings
have made it a problem because they
don't have a stable enough platform for
it the most important thing is this from
early childhood we must strive
to create a stable platform
within a human being
so that oh there's a whole system
of as there is a technology and science
for external well-being to create
external well-being similarly there's a
whole science and technology for inner
well-being but right now our life is not
about being wonderful our life is about
how to be better than somebody
i want you to be number two in the race
next indy 500 if both of us are there i
want you number two
who's number one
of course me
i'm saying this is the problem
that
you you're not seeing how to make this
into the most wonderful possible life
you're always seeing how to be better
than somebody
so this race is not just in the
racetrack on the racetrack it's okay we
know it's a sport all right but this is
with life itself now
if you are on the racetrack what is your
goal you want to hit the finish line
first right
are they doing this how are they doing
you're totally right that's exactly how
they do it yeah sometimes they use you
want to see the checkered flag that's
right quick
so if you believe your life is a race
what do you think is the finish line
that's a great question
uh
enlightenment or death maybe someone
thinks death i don't know
what is the finish line for life
for the race the finish line is
checkered flag right for life the finish
line is coffin
yes yes do you want to get there soon
no no
then don't think it's a race it's not a
race against anybody
this is about you blossoming to your
fullest possibility
so many people would say how do i
accomplish anything if i don't have
goals and i don't
have some kind of inertia pushing me
through life and
inertia doesn't push inertia slows you
down
right now that's all they're doing
because see let us say you have only one
leg
and you're hopping around
i have two legs but i want to be better
than you what will i do i will try to
hop a little faster than you how
ridiculous is that
that's ridiculous
you just run that's what is happening
that's what is happening to people
i was just telling somebody it once
happened
i'm sorry i've just said that in another
talk i had an hour ago but let me say
this because it's very important because
you're a racer
and in the race of course you want to be
the first one to cross the line you want
to see the checkered flag first nothing
wrong with that because as long as you
understand it's a sport
but everybody wants to see the checkered
flag in their life ahead of everybody
that means they'll see the coffin ahead
of everyone even they may not exactly
die but even when they're alive they're
like they're dead they're not alive to
anything all right this is what happens
to them because they're always looking
at who is going ahead who's going behind
so i was just telling this person
this is probably i was 9 or 10 years of
age
so those days and even now i think they
have this system that every month
a report card is given in the school
right
i never understood how my home and
school were connected
i just didn't understand but this report
card was a connection transaction
between my teacher
and my father
and it's a private letter why should i
open it and see i never used to open and
see
i understand it or every time he saw it
he freaked
i thought she must have said something
nasty to him but she was saying
something nasty about me
so once i gave the card and
i had gotten 33rd rank
i was 33.
my father asked how many students in
your class i said 33 of course
isn't 33 a bigger number than number one
hello
yeah
how many championships would you like to
win 33 or 1 33.
there you go
this whole nonsense we are starting from
kindergarten that you must be better
than somebody what it means is you enjoy
other people's failings
that is sickness that's not joy
it seems like the world is set up kind
of wrong all wrong
we need to fix it what is the solution
well we need to create a conscious
planet that's what we're striving for
right now to create a more conscious
planet if you were conscious you
wouldn't be doing this
you have evolved
out of your monkeyness quite some time
ago
but you're still not acknowledging it
see when i if i say you're monkeying
somebody what does it mean praying
you're imitating somebody right that's
what it means it's synonymous being a
monkey is being synonymous with
imitation
so
we still though
evolution has pushed us out of that
monkey status
1.23 percent
[Laughter]
but it's a world of difference
1.23 is a world of difference but we are
not giving up the old habits this is
karma
so karma means
you are evolutionary see in your body
there is memory of every creature
it is not like you as a person became an
amoeba then a grasshopper then this that
not like that as life on this planet has
evolved this body remembers every other
structure of life that is there and that
is why it can maintain its integrity
even if you give it cat food
it can maintain its integrity because
this memory is 100 set
you can't take it somewhere else
you can try to behave like them but this
structure will remain the same because
there is evolutionary memory well
established in the system
similarly genetic memory karmic memory
all these things are there how to be
about that needs
a conscious approach to life
right now karma gives us an automatic
autopilot to our life
if you just go by our karma
everything is by the tendencies we have
developed it will simply happen somebody
will become this somebody will become
that in a society
but if you want to be about that you can
only do that by being conscious
how to be conscious simplest thing right
now millions of people are doing this
simple process called as isha kriya
see because your karma or all memory
that you have evolutionary genetic
karmic this that every kind of memory
that you have
exists only in your body
and another body which you refer to as
mind but you don't know where it is
hello
right you don't know where it is
everybody says it's it's not like that
every cell in the body has its own
intelligence and its own memory all
right
so there is a mental body there is a
physical body
if you distance yourself from your
physical body and your mental structure
this is the end of karma
because that's where the memory bag is
if you keep the memory bag aside
it's there you know like people can't
keep their phone aside now because like
this like this because it's got some
thousand gb of some nonsense all right
going on
if you just keep it aside and switch it
off
you can sit yeah it's over
right
but they can't do it
because they have no means they've never
seen how because it is not about the
form
it is because you're compulsive it may
be a phone it may be a cigarette maybe a
drink it may be a food it may be a
person
you can't keep your hands free because
you're compulsive
it may be your
longing for food or pleasure or
something but essentially you're
compulsive
if you're compulsive
you kind of denying your evolutionary
status
because the significance of being human
is we can be conscious
we not doing anything very different
from what the other creatures are doing
they are also just born like us
you know their parents came together
they were born our parents came together
we we are born
we grow up
they grow up very easily we grow up with
a lot of fuss
then what is the next significant thing
that you do as a generation if you look
next thing is maybe we will reproduce
and they will reproduce without fuss you
will reproduce with a lot of fuss and
one day you will die that also with a
lot of us they do it more gracefully
so everything that you do every and to
elephant everybody is doing it
only thing is we can do it consciously
this is a massive difference
that we can do the same simple things
consciously suddenly it's another space
suddenly it's a completely different
possibility if you do not exercise this
ability to be conscious
in every act that you are because
consciousness is not in the act that you
perform right now i hear that
everybody's saying be mindful of this my
be mindful of that mindfulness will make
you a little more alert maybe you'll
survive better than others but
consciousness
is your existence